while the club has its master's degree made
up of abertis paz de shiíes
before new moon phases our group has
set the pace
[Music
] despite everything we fulfilled our duty
first the European vaccination strategy
we had the vaccine in record time and
we were able to distribute it in solidarity
We have also been able to promote a
recovery plan based on solidarity.
This is how we have managed to bring the
European project closer to the citizens. We
have faced very difficult challenges,
such as the weakening of the rule of
law in some of our countries, and
we have also led the  green deal
the climate law the balance between
environmental policies and
social policies but now it's time to
develop all this we are the only
political family that has a proposal
there is a vision for a fair transition
towards a society that is more supportive,
greener, more sustainable, more just more
egalitarian more feminist let's go for
the 2024 elections is new  At this
moment, each one of us,
individually, is necessary,
but collectively, together we are
essential, so work and move
forward
[Applause]
[Music]